on your left
so when they needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new black panther 2 marvel video they
just announced some big details about what's
happening with the movie you'll be surprised
by some of it so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's going to be a bunch of really
big stuff coming up marvel just made a bunch
of big announcements about a bunch of different
movies we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave all your theories about black panther
2 on the video and just recently i also donated
the money from my chadwick boseman videos to st
jude's charity that was chadwick boseman's
big charity that he spent a lot of time with
but just starting with the big stuff first number
five recently the hollywood reporter did a big
feature on the marvel phase 4 and marvel phase 5
movies that they're getting ready to start filming
and revealed a bunch of big details about castings
and what's going on and black panther 2 was just
the focus of a big part of that it's sort of
a follow-up they did with the marvel people
since it's been a couple months since chadwick
boseman unfortunately passed away and everyone's
just still been so shocked about it all no
one really knew what marvel was going to do
with black panther 2 at the time how they were
going to handle it because reportedly chadwick
boseman had been telling people around him that
he was expecting to be able to fully regain all
the weight that he'd lost because his cancer
had taken a turn for the worst in the last year
and they had planned to start filming black
panther 2 in the spring next year so he was
absolutely certain that he was going to be able
to bounce back after he passed away everything
just froze for a little while kevin feige and ryan
coogler the director both issued really touching
and respectful statements about how much chadwick
boseman meant to them how much of an amazing
person he was in real life in how much they wanted
to honor his memory particularly ryan coogler
it wasn't until a few weeks later after that
though that reporters started asking the cast
particularly letishia wright who plays shuri
his little sister in the movie what was going
to happen with black panther 2 and this is back
in september but at the time she just said that
we can't even think about it right now it's too
much to process with his death it's too soon but
this past week in november in hollywood reporters
article they list a bunch of details about when
marvel is going to start filming the movie next
year that's right they're going to start filming
black panther 2 next year and what the story is
going to be and what some of the characters are
going to be obviously everyone is wondering how
they're going to do this without chadwick boseman
so to speak so number four they reported that
marvel will start filming black panther 2 at
the beginning of july 2021 next summer originally
like i said it would have been in the spring but
that was before the virus delayed everything and
then obviously they needed some extra time to just
process chadwick boseman's death and figure out
how they were going to handle that in the story
marvel issued an official statement from one of
the producers saying that they were definitely
not going to be doing any kind of deep fakes
or cg replacement t'challa in the movie they
were basically saying that they're not going to do
the star wars carrie fisher thing with the rise of
skywalker they used a lot of technical wizardry
to sort of add her back into the movie with a
combination of cg and deleted scenes from earlier
star wars movies that doesn't mean that they won't
have any chadwick boseman black panther scenes
or t'challa scenes in the movie at all it just
means that you're not going to see them fake any
of it there's still a lot of extra footage from
the first black panther movie from captain america
civil war avengers infinity war avengers end game
that they could use to explain in the context of
the story what happens to him but i'll address
that in a second because number three also as part
of this new report one of the things that they
focus on is that marvel is beefing up shuri's role
in the movie significantly that's the way they put
it saying that her role would be much much larger
now which most people are taking as a sign that
they're doing the comic book shuri story of her
taking the mantle of black panther from t'challa
when he was stuck in limbo if you're not a big
comic book reader she took the mantle of black
panther a couple different times for extended
periods for different reasons each time though the
first time was when he was stuck between the world
of the living and the dead but he had trained her
to take the mantle so that she could if something
like that ever happened in the future then later
after he was safely returned to the world of
the living she kept the mantle of black panther
even though he was around because he wanted to
focus on the task of being king and felt like he
couldn't be a good king and be black panther at
the same time so t'challa effectively separated
the role of black panther from the role of king
that was around the doom war arc in the comics
where dr doom invades wakanda to try and steal
its vibranium everybody in marvel comics wants
that sweet vibranium honey the only time wakanda
has ever been invaded and it wasn't to steal their
vibranium was when namor and the atlanteans struck
them in retribution when he gained the powers of
the phoenix neymar and black panther had been
enemies for a long time in the comics he was just
one of the few antagonists black panther had that
didn't want to steal anything from him other than
his pride and his life speaking of which the next
big announcement that they made in this big black
panther 2 report is that marvel has already cast
the main villain of the movie everyone assumed
that namor would be their top pick now that marvel
has the x-men and fantastic four characters back
and we're starting to get mutants in the
wandavision series but the person they've
cast is tanakh huerta from narcos mexico and he
looks like he could pass for a number of different
major black panther villains from the comics they
didn't confirm who he's playing that's still a bit
of a secret just that he'd be the main villain but
he does kind of look like he could be a version
of namor but until they confirm more characters
or we see some early pre-production concept art
it's wide open to theory crafting it's just that
everybody points to that scene from avengers end
game because there were so many things that they
teased for marvel phase 4 during avengers end game
with the underwater earthquake in the atlantic
ocean that they were teasing atlantis because we
know from nick fury's map way back in marvel phase
2 and iron man 2 that atlantis is right there
smack dab in the middle of the atlantic ocean also
black panther 2 is one of those major avengers
level movies expecting them to introduce really
big concepts and new characters set during marvel
phase 5. it's coming out may 2022 they haven't
changed the release date yet that's around the
time in the marvel movies release schedule people
are expecting to start seeing more of the x-men
fantastic four-based characters start showing
up like more mutants and mutates and speaking of
x-men characters and good news we just learned
a bunch of details about the deadpool 3 movie
at marvel i'll do a separate video about that
this weekend but it's all really really good news
so there'll just be a lot of stuff with mutants
happening by 2022 in the movies in the disney
plus series but number two what does this mean for
the future of the black panther character without
chadwick boseman and how are they going to handle
that from a story perspective because right after
avengers end game we got spider-man far from
home and they used the entire beginning of that
movie to address all the people that at least the
world thought had died during avengers end game
so when big avengers characters pass away within
the story universe they do address it in future
movies as they stated in the report shuri becoming
one of the main characters of the movie it does
sound like at least within the world of the mcu
t'challa will pass away somehow or wind up in
the ancestral plane and this new villain will pose
some threat that's greater than killmonger because
it's a sequel and sequels are all about escalation
necessitating shuri become the new black panther
and the new queen of wakanda he had no children so
the throne in the mantle of black panther passed
to her by rights but i know a lot of you have
also asked how would she become black panther
if killmonger burned all those heart-shaped
herbs that they used to give them their powers
and connection to boss the panther god there's
actually a couple really easy ways for them to
explain her gaining black panther level powers
there's the very obvious quote unquote we found
more herbs growing in a secret previously unknown
place inside wakanda two there's the comic book
concept of introducing the panther god boss in a
bigger way like boss actually becomes a character
in the movie granting her divine powers of black
panther and three probably the easiest in the
way that makes the most sense is that she gets
all of her powers from her technology just like
iron man did iron man is one of those unique
examples of a super powerful top tier avengers
member who doesn't have any real powers he gives
himself power through all of his tech and science
shuri can do a version of that same thing with her
unique brand of tech that's all based on vibranium
science and the data that she harvested from
the infinity stones during avengers infinity war
sure his version of black panther in the comics
was a little bit different from t'challa's but mcu
shuri is already very different from comic book
shuri so it's not a huge stretch for them to pull
off in number one you also have to consider this
doesn't account for any multiverse storytelling
so keep in mind that marvel phase 4 is all
about multiverse tropes and alternate versions
of characters we already know for example
in the loki series that we're going to be
seeing next year it's going to feature multiple
alternate loki's like the kid loki female loki
in one that they're calling classic loki like
the walt simonson version of loki super evil loki
there's going to be two versions of thor during
thor 4 so there's always the possibility that
an alternate universe version of black panther
comes from the multiverse in black panther 2 but
unless this new actor they're saying is supposed
to be the main villain is an evil alternate
version of t'challa i'm expecting the new mcu
black panther to wind up being shuri until they
say otherwise i know a lot of you have said what
about michael b jordan coming back as killmonger
from the multiverse is black panther well michael
b jordan has three movies that he's acting in next
year and he's producing the live-action static
shock movie so he is booked solid i don't think
that he has any time to come back and be a
version of black panther again but everyone
post all your theories in the comments if they
say that they're not doing digital replacement
for chadwick boseman how do you think they're
going to explain the new black panther of the mcu
what's going to happen is my deadpool 3 video will
post either later tonight or tomorrow i've also
got a new mandalorian video that i'm working on so
as long as you have alerts enabled for my channel
you should see all those videos when they post
everyone click here to learn what's going on with
thor 4 and the avengers crossover they're doing in
that and click here for my full mandalorian season
2 episode 4 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!